a spring snowstorm is affecting 35
million people in the East this morning
after it brought near whiteout
conditions to the Midwest snow is
already accumulating in New York City
and its suburbs this is a live look
outside our broadcast Center in
Manhattan on April second into
springtime folks around 2 inches could
fall in New York City when it all ends
parts of Pennsylvania and West Virginia
could see a half foot DeMarco Morgan is
tracking conditions in Brooklyn New York
DeMarco how's it looking you know what I
don't even know why I'm smiling this
morning but it is a good morning indeed
but yesterday of course it was a
beautiful spring Sunday Easter morning
here in New York City and now people are
waking up to this just one big mess in
fact some of the cities that are in the
storm's path they will have gotten more
snow than they've had in the past decade
that's not good news but there is a good
news a good part of the situation about
this system right here because it's
going to be moving through pretty fast
but not before leaving out near whiteout
conditions in the Midwest causing a
number of accidents on the highways
there it also swept across Pennsylvania
leaving a slippery commute in parts of
that area where some areas could see as
much as 8 inches of snow this is already
a snow year than normal year here in New
York City we're nearly a foot ahead of
the seasonal average and other cities
like Pittsburgh in Boston in Portland
Maine are also well ahead of their
average snowfall totals and on the
bright side any snow that falls today
will likely be out of here by the
evening but there's always a but to
every situation we could see another
chance of so sometime next weekend and
John I gotta tell you this is my third
time living in New York City I have
never experienced a spring like this
would it ain't over yet DeMarco thanks
you know they promised me it would be
spring when I returned I want back on
that promise thank you thanks DeMarco